[MUSIC]
You may be surprised that I'm wearing a
tie today.
Indeed bioinformaticians are hardly ever
dressed like this when they give talks.
However 60 years ago, James Watson and
George Gamow form the RNA Tie Club.
The goal of this club was to decode the
genetic code.
There were 20 members in the club,
one for each amino acid, and the mission
was
to figure out which codons code these
particular amino acids.
The members of the club met twice a year,
smoked cigars, and drank wine.
And moreover, they understood the
importance of mathematics and biology.
So one of those 20 members was
a famous mathematician, Nick Metropolis,
who was actually
one of the founding fathers of
randomized algorithms.
However with all this firepower, there
were eight Nobel laureates in the club.
They have not decoded the genetic code.
The honor of decoding genetic code went to
Marshall Neirenberg who did
it in 1961.
Today we will talk
about arguably the more difficult task,
decoding the known ribosomal code.
I'm sure that 99% of students in this
class, before the class started, thought
that the only way to produce, to assemble
amino acids into a protein or
a peptide, was to have a ribosome and to use
RNA as a template.
However, as we learned in the antibiotics
lesson, there is another highly
unusual mechanism for producing peptides
and
assembling amino acids into peptide
chains.
It's called non-ribosomal peptide
synthesis.
And Mohamed Maraheil 15 years ago, set on
the goal to decode the non-ribosomal code.
Extremely difficult task.
Non-ribosomal peptide synthesis
is performed by a giant protein called
non-ribosomal peptide synthetase
or NRP synthetase.
And the task that
Marahiel was facing was this one.
NRP synthetase in bacillus brevis, as we
learned
code 10-amino acid peptide Tyrocydine.
But what particular amino acids in NRP
syntetase
are responsible for synthetizing, let's
say, valium in tyrocidine?
Non-ribosomal synthetase in Streptomyces
Roseosporus
codes for antibiotics of a last resort
called daptomycin.
But at the time when Maraheil started, it
was
absolutely unclear what particular segment
in NRP synthetase
in Streptomyces Roseosporus cause for
Daptomycin.
However, Maraheil knew something about
non-ribosomal peptide synthesis.
It is performed, as I mentioned,
by a giant molecular assembly line, NRP
synthetase.
And for every amino acid being
synthesized,
there is a segment in NRP syntetase
roughly 600 amino acids long called
adenylation domain.
So this adenylation domain synthesizes one
amino acid at a time, and since tyrocidine
is 10 amino acids long, there must be 10
adenylation domains in
NRP syntetase in this case.
So, what are the particular
amino acids, or what is the non-ribosomal
code that decides what amino acid
to synthesize.
Well Maraheil started by
taking a look at some adenalation demands,
and he argued that
despite, let's say, this three adenalation domains code
for different amino acid.
So there must be something similar in
them, because they
all tried to accomplish the same goal,
to add one amino acid to the growing peptide
chain.
He looked at the amino acids in these
three adenalation domains and found very
little similarities.
There is hardly any similarity here
only three conserved columns, which is
statistically insignificant.
However, if you just start shifting some
of the sequences, like I just did, you see 11
conserved columns.
And if you continue doing this, suddenly
you reveal 19 conserved columns.
This is statistically very significant,
which reveals
that these adenalation domains are indeed
similar.
We have just constructed the conserved
core of adenalation domain.
The next line
of attack for Marahiel was to figure out
which positions in these adenalation
domains
are actually responsible for coding
different amino acids
or which of them are different?
And he succeeded by finding eight blue
positions
that are actually responsible for
specificity of the amino acid synthesis.
As a result,
Marahiel was able to crack the non-ribosomal
code, and it turned out to
be extremely complex.
Eight amino acids located in different
parts of the adenalation domain, code a singe
amino acid as shown on this slide.
But if we didn't move
shift some amino acids in some
sequences compared
to others, we would never be able to find
the conserved blue columns.
So it now looks like a card trick, a
magic trick that Marahiel perform.
How in the world he was able to figure out
how to align
sequences in such a way that he was able
to reveal the conserved column.
Today, we will learn how biologists
compare biological
sequences, but before we move there, I
will tell you about one more biological
success story, the story of hunt for the
cystic fibrosis gene.
We now move to 1980s, when biologists were
trying to
find the cystic fibrosis gene.
Cystic fibrosis is an
often fatal disease of the respiratory
system that produces an
excessive amount of mucus, a slimy
material
that is secreted into fluids such as
saliva.
Cystic fibrosis is a rather frequent
genetic disease.
In the United States, one in 25 people
carries a faulty cystic fibrosis gene.
It doesn't mean that they have cystic
fibrosis, but if 2 people with faulty
cystic fibrosis genes have a child, there
is a 25% chance that the
child will have cystic fibrosis.
When in the late 1980s, biologists
narrowed the search
for the cystic fibrosis genes to a small
region
on chromosome 7, the question arose which
particular gene
in this region is responsible for the
cystic fibrosis?
And at that time, genetic mapping
techniques were limited
so they couldn't narrow the
search first.
As a result, they started to look at those
genes, and decided to compare each
of the candidate genes in these narrow
regions to all known genes in that time.
And one of these comparisons revealed that
one of those candidate genes in chromosome
7 is similar to an ATP binding protein
that acts as transport
channel responsible for secretion.
Remember, cystic fibrosis is related to
secretion, and
ATP binding proteins are also related to
secretion.
That was an eureka moment, and
biologists conjectured that this specific
candidate gene,
thanks to the similarity search,
is actually the gene responsible for cystic
fibrosis.
They called the gene cystic fibrosistrans
membrane conductance regulator,
or CFTR.
And the CFTR protein controls
the flow of ions in and out of cells
inside the lungs.
If a mutation happens inside the CFTR
protein, then
the flow of ions is disrupted, and it
leads to
cystic fibrosis.
In fact, it turned out that just three
nucleotide deletions in this gene disrupt
ion channels and causes cystic fibrosis.
And now the time has come for us,
to look at what algorithms,
biologists use to align
adenalation demands, or to
compare various candidate genes
in the case of search for cystic fibrosis.